Speaker 1: OK, let's go.
Let's go next.
Where are we going next?
It's just it's hard to know because the phone
calls are so widespread.
Let's try going to South Cat South.
Cat, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Oh.
South cut out, my goodness, hello, David Howard.
Speaker 1: Oh, are you Scottish?
No, Australian.
Oh, Australia, oh OK, sorry, I misheard your
accent initially welcome.
Speaker 4: Thank you so much.
Yeah, a lot of people probably expect me to
sound like Crocodile Dundee with shrimp on
the Barbie, but no.
Well, thanks for taking my call.
I just.
I just want to watch having the chips.
Somebody wrote recently about.
Well, his thoughts were that the build back
better plan had an effect on inflation.
Like a market.
What from what I believe?
Quite a bit of an effect on inflation, I thought.
I didn't necessarily agree with that, but
our audience thought, if you
Speaker 1: know, I don't think so, inflation
has been.
Inflation pre-dates the infrastructure package
passed by Joe Biden, and it also is global,
including, you know, affecting countries that
have nothing to do with American infrastructure
spending.
So I've seen no evidence that that is the
case.
Speaker 4: Well, thank you for that.
I appreciate it.
I hope hopefully you might be listening.
And just another thing I just wanted to say,
I really appreciate your the forensic nature
in which you comment on.
Words, the rhetoric that people in the media,
whoever they are, over a broad spectrum, it's
really important words matter.
You know,
Speaker 1: I appreciate that very much.
Speaker 4: You're good at it.
Yes.
Speaker 1: Southcott, thank you.
Listen, is it is it like 1:30 in the morning
in Australia right now?
What time is it there?
Speaker 4: It's it's 240.
I'm doing a.
Yes, network.
Speaker 1: It's the middle of the night.
Is it the middle of the night?
Speaker 4: Yes, it is.
Two to 40 am, right?
Yeah.
You have no idea when I have to get a lot
of work done so.
But.
Oh, and one more thing, I just just one quickly.
I also appreciate you mentioning the situation
with health care.
Especially with I saw that I think it's Kentucky
has have banned abortion.
Yeah, I'm not sure if this is disturbing.
I really feel.
Bad about it.
So.
Hopefully things will get better.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: All right, Southcott, you've set
it all.
Thank you so much for the call.
Speaker 4: Thank you, David.
Thank you very much.
Hear about the good work.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Thank you.
There is Southcott from Australia, the middle
of the night, the witching hour, as some as
some might call it.